the last stop of the workshop is
mcmc learning uh and why don't you give
it up
thanks everyone for coming to the last
talk and thanks to prasad and all the
organizers for a wonderful workshop
and as being the last talk of this
workshop i'm
i'm going to take the liberty of talking
about something that's a lot more
speculative than things that you've seen
so far in this workshop so
let's see how it goes can you speak up
yeah okay
okay so here's an outline of my talk
i'll first very briefly talk about
uniform distribution learning and all
the nice things that we can do there
and then
unfortunately
if one is interested in learning in
practice the uniform distribution on the
boolean cube is just not a model that
people like
and the rest of the talk will try to see
how much of this theory we can
hopefully use for more interesting
classes of distributions
so uniform distribution learning has
been around for at least 25 30 years now
and the idea is there's some target
function defined on the boolean cube
coming from some class and you want to
learn this
and there are various models that have
been studied for
for access to the function so
and here are some classes that sort of
the in some sense the richest classes
that are known to be learnable in these
settings
so for random examples there's this
algorithm by
o'donnell it's a video for learning
monotone decision trees
the random walk model is a richer one
where
instead of just getting iad random
examples the learning algorithm gets
examples from a random walk on the
boolean cube
and under that model uh since bishouti
moscow or donald
that you can learn dnf expressions
and the membership query model where the
learning algorithm can actually ask for
a query of each point what the function
value is
so jackson showed that you can
learn dnfs and also richer class site
literature classes thresholds of
parities and then the main tool for
all of these algorithms is the discrete
fourier analysis which you've seen a lot
in this last week
and and also many of these results and
other learning algorithms use quite
sophisticated results from
theory of boolean functions that we
uh
such as hyper contractivity the
invariance principle and so on
right so there's all this nice theory
but unfortunately
unfortunately
the uniform distribution on the boolean
cube is not just not a model that
is very relevant in practice and so the
question is do we have to
throw out all of this wonderful theory
or at least can we hope to
salvage some of it
for learning under broader classes of
distributions
and the particular class of
distributions we look at is
distributions that are given by markov
random fields
so what's a mark of random field it's
defined by some graph on n nodes
and each node in this graph is going to
be associated with some
variable which takes
a value in some finite set a
right and the distribution so this
defines a distribution over the set a to
the n
and is given by
these functions so with each clique in
the graph
there's a non-negative function
associated with it
and
and the probability so for if you for
any setting of
assignments of the variables for each
node
you can define a probability that's
proportional to this and the product of
all the cliques in the graph so
so this is
defines a distribution on some set a to
the n
and
so what are these models so these
these models have been
very popular in in various fields
as such as in machine learning or in
computer vision computational biology
and
lots of other fields
and
there's also a lot of algorithmic theory
around these models so this theory is
for sampling from these distributions if
you're given the description of a markov
random field how to sample from these
and also in some cases for recovering
parameters of the
markov random field and the structure of
it so if you're just given unlabeled
data which you think comes from
mrf can you actually recover the
underlying mrf and there's been a lot of
work in this area
but as far as we are aware there is the
question of learning with so if you're
given some function that's defined on
the domain a to the n
with respect to the distribution
generated by some markov random field
can we learn this function so this
question has not been studied as far as
we're aware
and more generally the question of
interest is whether we can actually
utilize the structure of this mrf in the
learning problem because if you can do
distribution independent learning you
could
do it but if you
can you actually utilize the structure
of the mrf to learn things that you
wouldn't be able to do otherwise
let me just
briefly outline what the learning model
here is so there's some
mark of random field m s and
pi is the distribution associated with
this markov random field and the sum
function unknown target function defined
on the domain that
a to the n so it's a boolean function
the learning algorithm can get
id examples where
so these examples are drawn from the
distribution pi of the mrf
and
in addition to this we let's also assume
that the learning algorithm knows this
mark of random field in some way
and i'll make it precise in the next
slide what we
in particular need for the learning
algorithm to know with respect to this
in particular uh for
something from wirecraft's random field
there's a generic algorithm called the
gibbs sampling algorithm this is an mcmc
algorithm
and here's the description of the
algorithm so
so you start with any so this is a
markov chain you start with any point x
in a to the n
and at each step the markov chain is on
update going to update only one of the
variables in this
and update only one coordinate
and the way it does it is
uh it picks the coordinate which is
going to update uniformly at random and
the new value for that coordinate is
picked from
the conditional distribution so this
so fixing all the remaining variables
the conditional distribution on the
variable that is going to be changed it
draws a new value from that distribution
and then updates the value and you keep
repeating this so if you run this markov
chain
this has nice property that the
stationary distribution is
the mrf distribution itself
and
this sampling from the conditional
distribution is
is easy as long as the graph has
constant degree so if the graph has
constant degree then
then the conditional distribution
depends only on a constant number of
parameters and this sampling problem is
easy
and
we're only interested in the cases so
we'll focus on cases when this markov
chain is actually rapidly mixing as well
yeah
uh
poly n
okay so before i talk about what we can
do with these mrf let me just mention a
couple of markov random fields that may
be familiar to some of you so
so the first one is the easing model so
here again there's a graph
and each edge has associated with it
some introduction energy
and the configuration of a system so
each variable not just takes values in
minus one and plus one
and this is hamiltonian operator which
uh let's say if all will will only be
worried when all the betas are positive
so
if adjacent vertices have the same spin
that's that's preferred to them having
opposite spins and it defines a
distribution on
this on minus one one to the n
and it's it's known that first as long
as these betas are bounded by some
parameter which depends on the degree of
the graph the gibbs markov chain that i
defined in the previous slide is is
rapidly mixing
and that's what's typically known as the
high temperature regime so this is
a picture from that and the low
temperature regime the gibbs markov
chain doesn't actually mix and we
just not worry about that
okay
so a second example is graph coloring so
again here you have a graph
and let's assume that the number of
colors is is much larger than the degree
of the graph
the probability distribution is just the
uniform distribution over all valid
colorings of the graph
and again in this case the gibbs markov
chain is is rapidly mixing so so here's
some just a couple of markov random
fields that might some of you might be
familiar with
and now let me
move on just try and see what we can
actually
do with them
so let me recall what this scenario was
again so
omega which is a to the n is a is our
instant space or the state space
and this is a gibbs markov chain
associated with the random markov random
field
a nice property of this gibbs chain
which i didn't mention earlier is that
it's it's reversible so if the
stationary distribution of it which is
the mrf distribution is pi then this
whole switch so the gibson coefficient
is reversible and as a consequence of
that what we know is that
if you look at the eigenvectors of the
transition matrix
so each eigenvector of the transition
matrix is a function from the state
space to reals
and
all of these eigen all of the
eigenvalues are real valued for one and
the eigenvectors are orthogonal with
respect to this stationary distribution
so this actually form gives you an
orthonormal basis for representing
functions defined over
to the n
and then the obvious question is can we
do some sort of a fourier analysis using
this basis
so
the first side this approach seems very
naive because first of all each of these
eigenvectors says
is in its dimensions as some a to the n
and
these we have no idea how to even find
all of these eigenvectors and even if we
could then we still have to worry about
actually finding an expansion of any
function in terms of these eigenvectors
for learning
and while all of this is true the what
with being slightly optimistic we hope
that we can tackle hope to tackle at
least some of these problems
and
see what we can
okay so so we want to try and extract
eigenvectors of a transition matrix
and what we proposed uh to do this using
the power iteration method for finding
eigenvectors
right so
so let me start with some
function g defined on the state space
just let's say a boolean function or
even a real valued function maybe so any
function g has an expansion in terms of
the eigenvectors of this transition
matrix
and and what i want to do is try and
extract the eigenvectors that are
present in g
and
okay so so if i multiply g by the t
power of the transition matrix
what i'm going to get is that eventually
the st gets larger the
the term corresponding to the largest
eigenvector is going to dominate
and
in particular here i'm
multiplying by this
unit vector 1x which is again an a to
the n dimension that has one in the
position corresponding to the x which is
just a point in omega and zero square so
this is just
and if i rearrange the term slightly
what i get is
this quantity on the left is
just the first eigenvector the the value
of the first eigenvector at x
in g
plus other terms which are hopefully
much lower order than
so so continuing so what what do we get
now so let's look at this expression
uh
again so
so this the quantity 1x times pt is
actually nothing but
just the distribution on the state space
obtained by running the gibbs markov
chain for t time steps right so
if you start the markov chain at x and
run it for t times that's the
distribution you get and so this
when i multiply by x it's nothing but
just the expectation of g with respect
to that distribution
and
and that's something that we can
actually hope to estimate because we
have access to the markov chain
and
and this operator here should
look familiar so this is like the noise
sensitivity operator so if you imagine
that you were working with the uniform
distribution on the boolean cube and
then you have a standard markov chain
then this would depending on the value
of t that controls the rate of noise and
that's exactly the noise sensitivity
operator here
so
so the hope is you can
estimate the ledges by sampling
and get some
so okay so let me summarize here so
suppose i have
a function g for which i have some
compact representation so i give you a
black box or a circuit description of g
and
i also have access to the gibbs markov
so i can run this markov chain
then
for any x in the point we can
approximately output the value of the
largest eigenvector that appears in g
and g needs to satisfy certain technical
conditions which i won't state
explicitly here
but
um then we can try and repeat this
process if we if we do get a handle on
the largest eigenvector that's present
in in g uh we can subtract it off and
then hope to find the second largest and
so on
of course
because we yeah
uh so
we we don't need to so we'll get
something that's in the direction of the
first eigenvector so we can just
normalize in
eigenvector corresponding to the largest
eigenvalue yeah
um
so the obvious problem here is if as as
long as we're doing sampling using a
markov chain
the error in our estimation is going to
be at least inverse polynomial so
it it's it seems hard using this kind of
a technique to get any more than a
constant number of eigenvectors from any
fixed function g
subtracting out it will just add up
errors will add up too quickly to get
anything more than a constant number of
eigenvectors
so far i have not said what
functions what this function g is or
should be
so i guess it's one can come up with
lots of functions so here's a candidate
function that we thought of which is
so i fix some subset of the variables
and for those variables i fix any
assignment on those variables
and then
define this g sub s b
which is just this quantity here which
is the ident
indicator of whether x i actually takes
that value minus the probability that x
i that takes this value
and and again this function shouldn't be
surprising so
if this were the uniform distribution on
the boolean cup if you were on the
boolean cube this is exactly the parity
function
right so so this would be a natural
place to start with but you can think of
other functions that
you could want to use and try and
extract
eigenvectors from them
and the learning algorithm itself is is
very simple so
suppose you could come up with these
eigenvectors
some collection of them
now to estimate what the expansion of
the target function is in terms of this
you just need to take dot products
essentially because you have an
orthonormal basis
which is
which is very easy so these alpha j hats
are basically the fourier coefficients
of
the target function in terms of these
eigenvectors
right and
and what i've said here is that if this
is in some sense like a low degree
algorithm and i'll make precise a little
bit more precise in the next slide
so
so the parts of spectrum that was used
here is typically going to be
eigenvectors with high eigenvalues and
well the nice thing is that hopefully
these are more likely to capture signal
than noise but it's also mainly just
because this part of the spectrum is
easier to access so if you
if your function g that we started with
has
an eigenvector that has a very low
eigenvalue then it would be very hard to
actually use the power iteration method
to extract that because the noise just
adds up and
for
want of having at least one side that
says theorem on it let me write a very
informal version of what you can prove
so if you have some markov random field
or defined on some state space and
if there is a class of
these functions of g which
each function actually needs to satisfy
some technical conditions i've not
stated them very technically here but at
least what you needed is these functions
are bounded
and they have low l1 mass in some sense
so the sum of the
absolute values of
the coefficients in the eigen expansion
of g should be some it should be bounded
and you need appropriate gaps and
eigenvalues of the eigenvectors that
actually appear in g
so if you have that then you can extract
from each of these g constant number of
eigenvectors the constant depends on
what how these conditions are satisfied
and any function that can be
approximated using
the eigenvectors that you get from this
class of function g can be learned using
the algorithm on the previous slide
the algorithm itself is very natural and
and the reason i said this is sort of
like the low degree algorithm is that if
if you were indeed in the case that this
was the uniform distribution on the
boolean cube
these conditions are indeed satisfied
and you take the standard random walk on
this and the boolean cube the conditions
that we require are indeed satisfied
and so you can actually just run this
algorithm and it will give you all
the lower degree fourier terms
right now you might say that i'm
cheating because i started with these g
functions which are already parity
but but even if you started with say
conjunctions or disjunctions of a small
number of variables you'll still
actually be able to get
you'll actually find the parity
functions as the correct eigenvectors
using this
so
in some sense this is the right
generalization of the low degree
algorithm to more general fields
okay
we also did some very very basic
experiments with these on the easing
model and graph coloring
and
so if you so what we can think of is for
any x we're essentially
expanding on these features which are
corresponding to this eigenvectors
and
if you only use these features it we do
mildly better than just
linear regression using the original
features
we could also consider what happens if
we just construct higher degree versions
of these eigen features
clearly but
it turns out in the experiments we
observe that degree 2 regression using
these features actually does much better
than degree 1 regression
and also just better than polynomial
polynomial regression with the original
variables of degree two
and
we suspect that the reason why this is
happening is that these eigenvectors
that we find products of them are in
many cases close to being eigenvectors
themselves
since so in some sense this this higher
degree expansion is finding something
that's close to more eigenvectors that
we didn't originally have
right
here's
a couple of open questions so
the obvious open question is for
find for
take your favorite simple mark of random
field
favorite simple class of
functions is there any hope of showing
that
you can approximate all functions in
this class using
higher eigenvectors so eigenvectors
corresponding to high eigenvalues under
these
for this markov random field
also
so as i mentioned just on the previous
slide so the auxiliary functions that we
were using were these
parity functions essentially that depend
on small number of variables
and we suspect that so the g itself
depends on small number of variables and
so it feels that because of that the
highest eigenvector in g
is also localized in some sense and
this is why maybe the product of
eigenvectors are also themselves close
to being
eigenvectors
the question is can we understand what's
going on here better
for general mark of random fields
here's another
simple simple open question which so if
you instead of so far i talked about
gibbs markov chain which had only
unlabeled examples that we generated
from it if you if you do have access to
a labeled random walk can you do
anything that you couldn't do earlier
and
we can
show it as under
some conditions that the mrf needs to
satisfy you can learn k hunters by
essentially what's a trivial algorithm
they just identify all influential
variables
but even that seems to be hard if you
only assume that the gibbs markov chain
is rapidly mixing you need some more
conditions
chain which essentially leads to higher
order parities as the leading argument
i mean if instead of jumping having high
probability of jumping to
neighbors i have a higher probability of
jumping to neighbors with
even distances and then some
distribution and very small tiny
probability
okay so what i didn't say in this mark
of um
so one thing that i didn't say
explicitly was you wanted to be
connected and you also wanted to be a
periodic but
does it make sense to think about
analogs of like query learning models in
this kind of setting some kind of analog
would like to let's password
it's possible so yeah we didn't think
about it very much and
yeah um you know like the low degree
algorithm has some built-in noise
tolerance i mean is there some notion of
noise here that um
noise tolerance that
that you looked at for this model
like you know you're close to some
function f on some
right so
so if you're close in
the l2 sense then all of this will
hold
but
there is
is small in terms of the distribution of
the markov random field then the same
thing will hold
okay i meant more if like the value the
labeling that you're getting
are
perturbed okay
that concludes the workshop and
thanks for all
for coming and let's thank simon sevens
too